[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live vous le savez
on attend vos commentaires et vos
questions pour alimenter notre débat du
jour et nos débats du jour est
aujourd'hui pour débattre nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir
lucile schmid d'abord bonjour vous êtes
ex conseillère régionale d'île de france
ps membre du conseil de rédaction de la
revue esprit cofondatrice et
vice-présidente de la fondation la
fabrique écologique merci encore d'être
avec nous et face à vous vincent
trémolet de villers bonjour vincent vous
êtes directeur adjoint de la rédaction
du figaro je rappelle que vous avez
récemment publié et l'éloge de la
politique
un ouvrage édité chez tallandier merci
encore à tous les deux d'être avec nous
alors l'exécutif espère un retour à la
vie normale peut être dès la mi avril a
déclaré mercredi le porte-parole du
gouvernement gabriel attal un message
d'espoir entendu également chez certains
scientifiques
on écoute tout de suite entité piqué
l'idée c'est de se dire oui d'ici 6 à 6
à 8 semaines disons le on aura
certainement fait beaucoup de progrès en
matière de vaccination on aura bénéficié
des restrictions qui sont aujourd'hui en
place on aura certainement dû ajouter
des restrictions dans certains endroits
ont donc en effet dans ce délai là on
pourra certainement commencé à relâcher
certainement en douceur gentiment avec
un programme et je crois que c'est ça le
message c'est ça le message vous avez
été sensible voulu s'y limitent au
message d'espoir du gouvernement est ce
que en avril tout ira mieux
ce qui est compliqué dans ce message
c'est qu'il nous dise enfin gabriel
attal est d'ailleurs le je pense que
jean castex va le confirmer
tout à l'heure nous disent que ça ira
mieux mi avril et par ailleurs que nous
sommes sous la menace de nouvelles
restrictions et donc ça ça rend les
choses difficiles si vous voulez moi je
veux bien une une perspective d'espoir
mais j'ai du mal avec cette cyclothymie
c'est à dire que via une perspective
d'espoir mais si l'idée c'est d'ici une
dizaine de jours lorsqu'on habite à
paris
r- confiné comment réussir à croire que
mi-avril tout ira bien
donc c'est ça le sujet la deuxième chose
qui me frappe c'est que sur le front des
contaminations on voit bien que on nous
dit que les contaminations augmente
c'est le cas mais on sent toujours une
espèce de difficulté du côté de la
société française à prendre la mesure
des contaminations par exemple quand il
faut faire des tests salivaires à
l'école
j'entends que 15 % des parents sont
d'accord avec ça donc il ya toujours une
réticence à la fois je pense qu'on est
de plus en plus responsables mais il ya
une réticence par rapport à cette
question de la responsabilité collective
qui reste importante
et puis troisième point alors moi qui me
frappe c'est que je pense que si on est
aussi j'ai du mal à me déterminer
c'est que je trouve qu'on parle jamais
traitement en fait c'est à dire qu'on
nous parle du virus décontamination nous
parle des vaccins mais je crois qu'on a
amélioré par exemple suivi à l'hôpital
en ce qui concerne le traitement de
l'analyse en charge la prise en charge
90 mais je crois que pourra aussi des
traitements qui sont en train d'être
étudiées il ya eu un certain nombre
d'articles disant d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement n'agissait pas forcément
dans le bon sens pour soutenir les
entreprises qui mettent au point des
traitements et du coup je pense qu'il ya
des choses qui continuent à manquer dans
la communication à la fois tracé un
horizon il faut quelque part mettre des
étapes et là il n'ya pas d'étape certiat
vers le 15 avril ça ira mieux mais
peut-être d'ici dix jours vous serez re
confiné vincent trémolet de villers il
ya beaucoup de choses qui font qu'on
peut avoir un peu de soupe sont un peu
de méfiance d'abord les dates on en a eu
au mois de novembre
on nous a dit le 15 décembre il y aura
une revoyure pour savoir s'ils ont ou
les théâtres ils n'ont pas ouvert le 20
janvier les restaurants ils n'ont pas
ouvert le 20 juin le 15 janvier on nous
a confié on a dit on se revoit dans un
mois public plus perdre mon âme un side
couvre feu puis plus personne n'est venu
nous parler de cette histoire de
couvre-feu qui s'est installée de de
façon presque pérenne
donc il faut avoir un peu de on est
prévenu quoi il faut pas être naïf en
sont ensuite une fois qu'on a dit ça moi
je pense quand même que c'est important
la déclaration gabriela talent est
importante parce qu elle nous sort d'un
climat qui était un climat détestable
dans laquelle un certain nombre de
sachants dont les membres certains
membres du conseil scientifique nous
avaient installé qui était le climat de
l'épidémie éternelle c'est à dire
avec l'absence d'horizon tout ce qu'on
veut faire sur le plan sanitaire était
contredit immédiatement par une mauvaise
nouvelle alors d'abord il y avait les
événements qui devait provoquer des
flambées épidémiques on en a déjà parlé
ici noël la chandeleur le l'épiphanie
l'effet pique nique quand il a commencé
à faire beau bon et a eu sa et puis
ensuite il ya eu l'histoire des variants
qui devait d'abord contourner les
vaccins et puis ensuite installer une
combe et pour expo n'en ciel qui fait
qu'on aurait dû tout refaire mais ça ne
s'est pas passé au mois de février
tel que ça avait été prédit et moi pour
ça moi j'en veux à ceux qui ont tenu ce
discours là parce qu'ils ont installé
une forme de peur dans la population est
dans les esprits extraordinairement
malsaine et qui n'avait pas de fondement
scientifique stupeur préventive
oui c'était ça pourrait se passer comme
ça et donc je pense que la réponse de ce
que dit gabriela talent participe de
l'évolution des manuels macron face à la
pandémie depuis quelques semaines qui
consiste à dire maintenant ce sont les
faits qui commande ce ne sont pas les
projections ce ne sont pas les
modélisations se sont pas les travaux
que peuvent faire un certain nombre de
deux scientifiques
donc ça va voir dans cet optimisme
quelque chose d'artificiel même presque
une stratégie politique pour nous faire
patienter tout en sachant finalement ça
ne se passe pas aussi bien que ce qui
est en fait qu est-ce qui est tangible
la saison on sait pas grand chose on n'a
pas compris grand chose à ce virus
mais on a compris que quand on
on était plus dehors et que les la
température remonte et il circulait
moins donc on l'a vu l'année dernière de
façon pratique donc à partir de là on
peut penser que le 15 avril le climat
permettra des choses qui ne permet pas
ensuite il ya le grand défi et c'est là
que ces dates du 15 avril est un peu osé
sauf moi c'est mon hypothèse si macron a
demandé qu'on la prononce pour mettre
une pression maximum sur sa haute
administration
en dix ans pour tenir ce délai il faut
vacciner est donc là le seul moyen
maintenant c'est que le astrazeneca soit
donner le plus possible et vie va y
avoir la validation du vaccin johnson
and johnson va donner le plus possible
il faut aussi que les français voient la
lui donne un peu de créer oui mais ça
faut créer un élan et ça c'est la
politique de le faire
et puis johnson johnson qui doit être
homologué je crois la semaine prochaine
il ya qu'une dose donc ça va beaucoup
plus vite et donc le le voilà leur
injection donc le le l'objectif fixé par
macron neto nabeul que s'il y a une
accélération spectaculaire c'est à dire
1 millions par semaine je pense de
vacciner mais s'il tient ça c'est à dire
là on est le 1er mars si le 15 avril ya
6 millions de plus de vacciner on
arrivera à neuf c'est ça commencera avec
ce qu'ils ont garée a eu à avoir des et
l'objectif annoncé fin mars on devrait
atteindre les 9
on est censé atteindre les 9 millions de
vaccinés en première dose uniquement si
on suit l'évolution d'aujourd'hui à
raison de cent mille vaccin vaccinés par
jour pour une première dose
on n'atteindra que six millions de
personnes vaccinées on hier au grand
talent de défense et après sa parole à
lucile macro créer une lune
de nouveau piqué une colère en disant
pourquoi on a neuf millions de doses et
qu'il ya trois que tout simplement trois
millions de personnes qui ont une
injection
oui et que et normalement il devrait
mettre une pression maximum sur son
administration et sur la logistique pour
que les choses se fassent
après peut-être ça ne se fera pas mais
c'est ça maintenant mais ce que je pense
surtout c'est que là la différence dans
l'organisation des vaccinations sera
astrazeneca c'est que ce sont les
médecins généralistes qui vont vacciner
et du coup la question des coups de
colère de macron qui sont réelles et
tant mieux s'il se met en colère si ça
met un coup de fouet à la haute
administration
c'est que le problème c'est pas la haute
administration c'est quand même comment
est-ce que effectivement il faut livrer
les doses il faut que les médecins
généralistes vaccine et c'est donc là il
ya tous et pas seulement de la
logistique c'est en quelque sorte mille
fourmi qui doivent axer les et il ya
aussi une question de délai me
semble-t-il parce que au royaume uni où
ils ont choisi une stratégie de
vaccination massive et y compris en
espaçant les dos c'est à dire en faisant
qu'une dose et en faisant le pari
qu'elle allait très bien protégés c'est
seulement aujourd'hui qui voit les
résultats
alors évidemment il avait le variant
britannique est très contagieux mais en
tout cas ce qui me semble c'est que dans
cette histoire là moi je me suis
j'espère l'optimisme et je suis très
heureuse que les mails macron himself et
pris la décision de ne pas nous confiner
mais il me semble que tout ne dépend pas
des manuels ma croûte à dire que le
sujet c'est les médecins généralistes
l'arrivée des 12 dans les cabinets
médicaux et aujourd'hui ça fait une
semaine qu'on nous parle d'astrazeneca
et qu'on nous dit que c'est arrivé mais
ce n'est pas arrivé dans la plupart des
cabinets de médecins généralistes
essayer de voir chez vos proches sinon
ils peuvent se faire vacciner sur le
territoire français ce n'est pas le cas
et ensuite il ya un délai pour mesurer
si ça marche ou pas donc moi le 15 avril
je pense que c'est une décision
emmanuelle macro nien et que gabriella
talent fait ce que lui a dit de faire
emmanuel macron il faut évidemment dire
le 15 avril
mais la réalité médicale ou la réalité
sanitaire elle sera sans doute un petit
peu plus tard en revanche il va y avoir
évidemment évolution mais le problème de
des dates vous l'avez très bien dit
vincent sait que ces dates n'ont pas
forcément grand chose à voir avec ce que
nous vivons nous mêmes
de la même manière que quand anne
hidalgo a dit il faut confiné trois
semaines et ensuite on sera tous très
libre on a le sentiment que le temps des
politiques est un temps de communication
qui d'abord ne correspond plus à ce que
nous
pensons-nous et qui ensuite a du mal par
exemple
adressez-vous à votre médecin
généraliste il vous dira peut-être je
sais pas le 15 avril ses réalise le 30
ou je sais pas moi j'ai géré ma vie j'ai
envie de me lamenter de la réalité ans
est là c'est là où soit pour avoir une
formule un peu brutale emmanuel macron
et son équipe ne savoir rien soit ils
servent à quelques données cap
et oui mais normalement le exécutif qui
a exécuté
donc il ya un moment quand on prend une
décision d'une gravité comme celle-là
c'est à dire quand on est dans une crise
comme celle là il devrait y avoir une
chaîne de commandement et une chaîne
d'applications qui fait que le médecin
dont vous parlez et j'en vois où on en a
au téléphone qu'ils nous disent
soit j'ai pas de patients soit j'ai pas
de dose je pars en vacances à meadows va
exister balaïa décision politique moi je
vais en prendre une je vais en donner
une tout bête mais on a énormément de
doses on a un ça donne de passion qui ne
viennent pas se faire injecter on a des
catégories je défie quiconque de pouvoir
me dire qui a le droit de se faire
vacciner dans quelles circonstances avec
quel vaccin selon lui et où tellement
c'est compliqué on pourrait réfléchir à
l'idée de tout ouvrir en disant ceux qui
veulent se faire vacciner alesi et parce
que moi je suis convaincu que pour créer
un élan il faut créer un mimétisme est
donc une semi métis mme il se fait par
la force du mouvement c'est ce qu'a fait
beau rue johnson est comme ça que ça a
marché
il y avait sarkozy hier ou avant-hier à
la télé qui qui disait faut vacciner 7
jours sur 7 le matin et soir jour et
nuit
mais c'est même la prison c'est ça voilà
c'était pas loupé
l'essai mais il a raison sur le camp
politique il ay l'art et la raison sur
le temps que ça veut dire pour les
vaccins et quand on apprend qu'il n'y a
pas de vaccination le dimanche bonfa ccc
lunaire et ça c'est d'ailleurs un des
problèmes
c'est à une des révélations de cette
crise c'est qu'on a découvert moi j'en
suis désolé là le gouffre entre l'ordre
donné et l'application concrète et
pratique dans les mille endroits que
vous avez alors là une stratégie qui est
un peu bancal en tout cas qu'il n'y a
pas suffisamment vite sur sur la
stratégie vaccinale sur le terrain en
tout cas mais par rapport à l'optimisme
dont on parlait au début de cette
émission
tous les scientifiques ne partage pas
cet optimisme on va écouter tout de
suite 4 me catherine hill qui était
chemin ce matin chez nos confrères de
lci
rien ne permet de dire que ça va aller
mieux absolument rien et l'histoire que
le virus va devenir moins dangereux il a
autant de chances de devenir plus
dangereuse que moins dangereux le virus
qui mute bêtement et il circule plus
vite quand il est plus contagieux moins
vite si la mutation le rend moins
contagieux et la mutation peut le rendre
plus grave et la mutation peut le rendre
moins deux ans et non aléatoire c'est
trop gros
c'est aléatoire ces trucs là dit
catherine hill ici schmid on sait on l'a
dit tout à l'heure le virus circule
encore activement même si c'est pas de
manière homogène sur le territoire
est-ce que c'est pas prendre un risque
que de déclarer que les choses iront
mieux mi avril
on sait à quel point les français
peuvent se relâcher ne serait-ce que les
images qu'on a tous vu le week-end
dernier dès qu'il ya un peu de soleil
tout le monde lâche la pression est-ce
que c'est pas prendre un risque
aujourd'hui de dire les gars ça va aller
donc aujourd'hui on peut peut-être lever
le pied
avant même de laisser passer ces quatre
à six semaines où on nous demande
précisément de faire un effort moi je
crois que ils ont enfin le gouvernement
a raison emmanuel macron gabriela talent
et et compagnie ont raison de donner un
cas positif et optimiste
en revanche je pense qu'il faut
articuler ça vraiment à la stratégie
vaccinale et ça je trouve que c'est pas
clair c'est à dire que je prouve qu'on
devrait par rapport à ce que 10 à 20
sont tout à l'heure nous donner une
espèce de mode d'emploi très concret ne
comment ça va se passer et que ça serai
par exemple très très bien si gabriel
atta mills est bon voilà pour le 15
avril
eh bien à partir de la semaine prochaine
vos médecins généralistes ont reçu
toutes leurs doses et c'est alors que on
sait que ce n'est pas vrai aujourd'hui
c'est un est libre donc yarakh dans la
com il ya un élément qui manque ou il ya
un élément de faire attention d'être
toujours normand il faut aussi que
derrière l'homme sa compagne avec des
plannings on va dire il ya quelque chose
de pratique est par exemple
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya beaucoup d'
absurdité si vous voulez vous faire
vacciner fois les chaussures dr libre et
si vous êtes à paris
moi on m'a raconté le cas de quelqu'un
qui habitait en dessous ou au dessus
d'un centre de vaccination et qui voyait
des gens arriver de partout en ile de
france et qui lui ne pouvait pas se
faire vacciner alors qu'il habitait
juste au dessus du centre de vaccination
donc ces absurdités bureaucratique
je sais pas si c'est seulement la
logistique c'est quelque part que dans
le système d'accès au vaccin
je pense que le gouvernement devrait
travailler de façon à ce qu'on ait
l'impression d'un principe d'égalité et
que les catégories à risque sont bien
identifiés et correspondent aussi à une
réalité
donc je crois que cette stratégie
vaccinale c'est là que le gouvernement
quelques parcs risques ça vous fait une
dilution des responsabilités et une
absence de commandement dans le sens où
le commandement consiste à faire
appliquer des choses qu'on va demander
je vais vous prendre un exemple très
concret que m'a raconté un responsable
public au début du
vaccin de pfizer dont qu'il y avait
besoin de frigidaire à 80 me de
réfrigérateur il fallait en transporté à
lille depuis paris et donc on a demandé
à la personne qui était chargée est ce
qu'on peut faire ce transport il a dit
oui sous 10 jours
mais pourquoi sous dix jours ça se fait
en 24 heures ah bah parce que le
transporteur à qui j'ai demandé me dit
qu'il ne peut pas avant dix jours et là
normalement il faut un responsable qui
dit bon mes réquisitions ou et puis on y
va mais comme personne n'est
véritablement responsable puisque il ya
une espèce de chêne infini dans laquelle
on a du mal mais nous journalistes quand
on veut se plonger dans les
responsabilités entre ce qui tient de
l'administration préfectorale ce qui
tient de la rs qui tient des hôpitaux
on ne sait pas on ne sait plus où donner
de la tête
et à partir de là cette dilution de la
responsabilité fait qu'il ya une lenteur
dans l'application
moi ça vous dit de 17 mars on va fêter
les 1 1 de cette épidémie et des
périodes de confinement qu'on a vécu
depuis un an cette brouillard on va dire
sur le terrain ils auraient pu être
exactement enfin il semble qu'au lieu de
nommer des monsieur et madame vaccin ou
d'écouter des monsieur et madame
épidémiologistes si on pouvait nommer
des monsieur et madame je sais pas si
c'est logistique mais en tout cas
responsable de l'application
opérationnel de la campagne de
vaccination
ça serait super et ça je suis persuadé
qu'il ya dans l'administration des gens
qui seraient capables de le faire qu'il
faudrait en nommer d'ailleurs je sais
pas à l'échelle des territoires
pertinents qui travaillent avec les
médecins d'accord que les médecins et un
numéro de téléphone qui puisse appeler
quand quand ils savent pas quand est ce
qu'ils reçoivent les doses enfin il ya
toutes ces sept éléments à mon avis pas
si compliqué que ça
mais sur lequel l'embarras de la
responsabilité me semble être un truc en
fait qui est absolument inexcusable
oui mais si on prend on va prendre un
exemple concret
je pense que si on pose la question aux
français est ce que vous connaissez
votre préfet peut-être ils savent est ce
que vous connaissez le patron de votre
adresse donc été préfet médicaux honneur
et du sanitaire personne ne les connais
je n'en connaissais même pas l'existence
de cette structure
avant cette crise et c'est ça que je
veux dire et il y en a sûrement qui sont
très bons c'est que je ne vais pas du
tout un jugement global en dix ans mais
il y a une espèce de déperdition de la
responsabilité qui fait que des choses
qui devraient aller vite sont lentes et
qui fait que gabriel attal ou d'autres
olivier ferrand dit ça va se passer
comme ci comme ça il y en aura salins et
puis comme vous dites quand on arrive
sur le terrain ça ne se passe pas donc
donc ça c'est la première chose à la
deuxième moi j'aimerais revenir sur ce
que vous aviez sur le relâchement
oui pour merrill placé en montre un peu
notamment sur les images de ce week end
c'est à dire que moi je comprends jeu
tout à fait que les gens enfermés chez
eux depuis quasiment deux mois avec un
hiver pénible sans cinéma sans
restaurant sans relations sociales quand
il fait beau et sur les quais et je ne
comprends pas qu'on le leur reproche et
je comprends encore moi qu'on envoie des
patrouilles de police les disperser
comme s'ils étaient des manifestants
sénat cieux et je terminerai en disant
citant monsieur prudhomme qui est un
urgentiste et qui dit en plus c'est pas
là qui se contaminent parce qu'ils sont
allés en plein air et en plein air c'est
là où il ya le moins de risque de
contamination et ça amène simplement à
un problème qui est rentré dans nos
esprits c'est qu'on n'assimile des
décisions administratives et
bureaucratiques à des décisions
sanitaires et on n'en sait rien par
exemple l'effet du couvre-feu le
week-end sur le plan sanitaire
personne aujourd'hui n'est capable de
dire si ça sera en tout cas laissez moi
vous faire part d'un commentaire d'un
internaute par rapport à cette stratégie
politique peut être derrière cette
décision d'optimisme on va dire j'en ai
marre c'est son surnom sur twitter
emmanuel macron n'aura pas le choix si
d'ici la fin d'avril les taux que nous
supportons avec résilience depuis la
mi-octobre ne se desserre pas il ne
pourra probablement pas se représenter
en 2022
la colère commence à monter et en effet
si la stratégie du gouvernement
ne s'applique pas au moment de la mi
avril
si l'optimisme affiché l'optimisme
affiché aujourd'hui ne se présentent pas
aux portes de la mi avril
que va-t-il se passer quelle va être la
stratégie du gouvernement qu'elle de
quels moyens disposera-t-il pour
redresser la barre pas ce qui est
important c'est que le gouvernement a
appris je pense à assumer davantage
l'incertitude et le fait de ne pas tout
savoir depuis quelques semaines et qui
effectivement avec la cette phrase de
gabriel attal énormément reprises parce
qu'elle correspond à une aspiration
enfin je pense que c'est ça qui est
important aussi de dire il ya un risque
si si les choses rebondissent comme le
disait cet épidémiologiste après en
l'écoutant je me disais mais c'est
incroyable en fait elle décrit les
choses comme si tout allait forcément
aller pour le plus noir donc ça rejoint
ce que disait vincent tout à l'heure sur
le fait que imaginez quand même qu'on
peut agir qui a la volonté qu'a la
possibilité d'aller mieux
moi je crois que c'est essentiel et je
pense que le gouvernement
et à gabriel attal emmanuel macron
pourront tout à fait justifié les choses
pourvu qu'on ait le sentiment que comme
on le disait tout à l'heure la question
opérationnelle soit prise en charge
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut à régler qui est
un bêtisier de la vaccination
alors que pour l'instant chacun a son
anecdote aller ce sera la solution
bêtise et la vaccination et on fasse
tout de suite à la réponse à votre
participation covit 19 en avril est ce
que ça ira mieux c'est la question que
vous posez sur twitter et vous êtes donc
75% de pessimistes puisque vous répondez
non à cette question et bien ça va à
l'encontre un peu de ce qu'on s'est dit
aujourd'hui sur le sujet allez on passe
à l'autre débat du jour beaucoup plus
lourd encore que celui qu'on vient de
traiter avec cette question qu'on vous
pose sur twitter guerre d'algérie
faut-il des excuses réciproque l'elysée
a reconnu mardi que le militant
politique algérien ali boumendjel a été
torturé et assassiné par l'armée
française pendant la guerre d'algérie en
1957 un meurtre à l'époque maquillé en
suicide on se souvient qu emmanuel
macron s'est engagé depuis le début de
son quinquennat dans une démarche de
réconciliation des mémoires entre la
france et l'algérie et qu'il avait
demandé à l'historien benjamin stora un
rapport sur la décolonisation et la
guerre d'algérie et la reconnaissance
d'assassinât mardi par emmanuel macron
bell fait partie des gestes d'apaisement
recommandé par l'historien justement
afin de résoudre les tensions autour de
la mémoire de ce conflit la guerre
d'algérie demeure encore aujourd'hui un
sujet sensible
preuve en est les réactions de la classe
politique française qui se sont succédé
depuis mardi à l'instar de
l'intervention de jean pierre raffarin
ancien premier ministre
il intervenait ce matin sur radio
classique
et naturellement ce qu'il vient de faire
sur l'algérie ne favorise pas forcément
cette perspective pourquoi parce que une
grande partie de l'électorat de droite
et pour que la repentance qu'on tourne
la page avec l'algérie mais de manière
réciproque la guerre ces deux blocs qui
s'opposent et donc il faut reconnaître
les drames d'un côté et de l'autre je
pense que ça fait partie des td des
sujets qui mobilisent les lectra
vincent trémolet alger a salué un peu
plus tôt aujourd'hui dans la journée la
reconnaissance par la france de
l'assassinât du nationaliste algérien
donc ali boumendjel est ce qu'on peut
considérer que cette reconnaissance en
tout cas ce salut d'alger par rapport à
la reconnaissance de la france que c'est
un premier pas on va dire vers une
possible réciprocité de la
reconnaissance des crimes
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse le
considérer encore maintenant parce que
il faut mesurer le poids que prend la
guerre d'algérie dans la rhétorique et
j'allais même venir dans la propagande
du pouvoir algérien vis-à-vis de sa
population c'est à dire qu'en général
quand il échoue à mai à améliorer le
sort de leurs populations il invoque la
colonisation française en rappelant la
culpabilité il le développe même la ce
se passe un phénomène très préoccupant
là bas qui est le l'installation de
façon de plus en plus forte et précise
de l'idée d'un génocide français qui ont
été pratiquées contre les algériens et
la personne qui entretient cela et qui
les aident et qui ont fait le sang fait
le porte-voix cr dogan qui a très bien
compris qu'ils pouvaient nous nuire en
installant cette rhétorique au delà même
des frontières algériennes donc je pense
pas qu'on puisse dire ça ensuite moi
j'ai un avis assez tranché sur ces
choses qui vont au-delà de la question
algérienne
c'est à dire que je pense que quand la
politique veut s'occupe de la mémoire
non pas pour évoquer des choses qui font
l'unité d'un pays où là il ya quelque
chose d'à peu près naturel c'est
extraordinairement peyrieu pourquoi
parce que c'est aux historiens de faire
le tri entre les choses qui se sont
passées qui ne se sont pas passées c'est
aux populations par les historiens et
puis par les formes qui accompagnent
l'histoire c'est à dire le livre le film
documentaire qui doivent regarder les
pages noble et les pages sombres de
l'histoire parce que tous les pays l'on
est que quand un homme politique le fait
il ya toujours un propos relevés on va
réconcilier les peuples
il ya toujours des arrière pensées
extrêmement petit par rapport à l'enjeu
là je voudrais citer le papier que l'on
a publié ce matin darty regarda haineux
paul suivi dans laquelle un conseiller
dans lequel un conseiller de macron dit
quand on voit les réactions du r n
à la décision d' emmanuel macron on voit
qu'il a bien fait de le faire parce que
ça montre qu'on n'a rien à voir avec le
rn donc on passe de la volonté de
réconcilier deux peuples qui se sont
affrontés dans une guerre
extraordinairement cruel à une petite
stratégie politicienne pour sauver le
débat darmana le pen c'est à mon avis un
exemple très concret 2 du danger d'aller
sur ce terrain glissant
lucile schmid moi ce qui me semble c'est
que entre la france et l'algérie on
parle sans cesse de mémoire d'ailleurs
benjamin stora est effectivement un
historien des mémoires remarquable il à
faire merveilleuse mémoire justement sur
messali hadj
il a raconté aussi son histoire puisque
c'est un sage juif de constantine il a
raconté l'histoire de ses parents dans
les clae retrouver enfin bon c'est
cesser cette magnifique mais c'est une
histoire personnelle et la difficulté
sur ses mémoires c'est comme le disait
vincent c'est que en fait sur l'algérie
à plusieurs mémoires vous savez il ya
évidemment la mémoire de ceux qui ont
fait la guerre
d'ailleurs dans des situations
différentes évidemment donc quand vous
étiez appelé c'est pas comme quand vous
étiez au fond vivant en algérie comme
français quand vous étiez combattants du
fln ça n'avait rien à voir
il y avait des choix différents des
choix militant ou des choix pas de choix
d'une certaine manière il ya la question
des pieds-noirs et en plus parler de
décolonisation c'est compliqué parce
qu'il s'agissait de départements
français
donc le sentiment que c'était la france
qu'on le veuille ou non ça reste quelque
chose d'assez puissant et par ailleurs
il ya une sorte de déni sur
l'enseignement justement de ce qu'a été
cette guerre entre la france et
l'algérie y compris en france alors même
que aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs millions
de français qui ont un lien avec
l'algérie un titre ou à un autre on
pense que c'est autour de 6,7 millions
donc comme pieds noirs comme franco
algérien comme personne ayant passé du
temps en algérie dans les années 70
comme pierre rouge comme on disait donc
cette complexité en fait du lien entre
les sociétés c'est à mon avis
historiquement important et aujourd'hui
ça travaille donc la question des
mémoires elle ne semble pas répondre en
fait à la question de la complexité de
la relation franco algérienne
je rappelle que par ailleurs le pouvoir
algérien est quand même le régime
algérien quand même extraordinairement
durs peu sourcilleux des droites sa
population vécu oui que ça descend bien
aimé
le mouvement du irakiens les plus beaux
qui est un des plus beaux mouvements
démocratiques qui s'est levé comme avec
ce qui se passe et hong kong
on a du mal à en parler en france on
parle plus de hong kong que du mouvement
du irak parce qu'on a une espèce de gêne
vis-à-vis de l'algérie
et ça tout ça me semble infiniment plus
importants à explorer que ce sujet au
fond de saucissonner les mémoires en
reconnaissant alors emmanuel macron sur
l'algérie il a toujours voulu être très
actif je rappellerai que pendant sa
campagne il a quand même parlé de crime
contre l'humanité
il était à alger me semble-t-il est là
est-ce que c'était franchement la bonne
expression je ne crois pas je crois pas
qu'il faille justement crimes contre
l'humanité ça équivaut à un génocide
il ya quelque chose autour de ça qui
travaillent donc moi je crois pas qu'on
puisse résumer ce qui s'est passé entre
la france et l'algérie un crime contre
l'humanité ensuite il ya eu ce qui s'est
enfin tout ce qu'il a fait autour de
maurice audin ce mathématicien
communistes et çà c'est je trouve ça
très bien je trouve que cette question
sur ali boumendjel est aussi
passionnante mais je ne crois pas que ça
permette d'élaborer une position
collective entre les sociétés et en ce
sens donc j'ai dit sur la question de la
réciprocité demander à alger
vous n'y trouvez pas je sais pas que
j'aie trouve pas d'intérêt c'est que je
ne crois pas un instant que le régime
algérien pratiquera pas je crois ce que
l'expression de réciprocité n'est pas en
fait
comment dirais-je adapter à cette
situation complexe
je pense que le régime algérien sera
toujours de mauvaise foi qui lie la
france qu'à ceux comme l'a dit vincent
de toute façon vis-à-vis de leur
population avec laquelle ils ont perdu
le lien et avec lequel ils n'ont aucune
pratique démocratique c'est une c'est
une espèce de réflexe de dire du mal de
la france et que nous n'avons pas la
capacité aujourd'hui à transformer ce
régime ça ne relève plus de nous on s'en
contente d'un simple et par ailleurs
l'ong nous sommes complices vous dis
venez moi je pense qu'il ya aussi en
arrière-plan
l'idée de se dire bon bah c'est un
régime injuste oui mais qui maintient
une forme de stabilité
oui il vaut mieux cette stabilité on est
cynique mais alors il vaut mieux cette
stabilité qu'une instabilité dont on
ignore où elle pourrait nous mener donc
il ya quand même un jeu
un peu la démocratie en algérie serait
elle aussi favorable à la france que ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en 2d se
contente de cet état de fait
donc ça ajoute moi je trouve aux
troubles de la décision de maquereaux et
puis il ya eu il ya un autre élément à
mon avis qui m'apparaît très près
rillieux et kiki qui montre un peu la
légèreté avec lesquelles on les choses
ont été apportées quant on parle et
quand on parle avec des anciens de la
guerre d'algérie où des gens qui étaient
pieds noirs ont des gens qui étaient au
chêne etc
ils ont en général un regard presque
plus complexe que ce et c'est pareil
avec la seconde guerre mondiale que ce
qui arrive très très loin derrière et
l'a fait emmanuel macron il y avait dans
la notion de crimes contre l'humanité
dans les propos qu'il avait confié
arthur berda notre journée du figaro
dans l'avion et dans d'autres
confidences l'idée de faire avec
l'algérie ce que chirac a fait avec le
discours du vel d'hiv et la
reconnaissance de la culpabilité de
l'état français et là il ya
l'installation d'une possible
équivalence entre deux événements qui ne
sont pas les rennais équivalent et qui
serait une équivalence particulièrement
choquant et donc je crois vraiment que
ils auraient tout intérêt sur le plan
politique à un an d'une élection
présidentielle a laissé les
intellectuels travail et je pense qu'il
y avait une rencontre entre benjamin
stora
kamel daoud qui est un écrivain algérien
boualem sansal qui est un écrivain
algérien un spécialiste d'albert camus
et d'autres gens qui parlaient des liens
entre la france et l'algérie ça serait
intéressant ça serait nourrissant que ça
serait utile mais que des politiques
brandissent des éléments historiques en
disant je vous donne ça vous me rendais
ça ça me paraît inutile et ça me paraît
dangereux mais il ya autre chose quand
même qui est important c'est que je n'ai
pas lu ce que disait ce conseiller
d'emmanuel macron sur le rassemblement
national
mais historiquement aussi les tout ce
qui n'a pas été assumée dans cette
guerre d'algérie à alimenter le vote du
rassemblement national de
une date dans le sud de la france et
donc là il ya quelque chose
effectivement qu'on le veuille ou non en
fond la question algérienne fait partie
du vote en france
et ça ça dépasse évidemment les
historiens moi ce qui me semble c'est
que benjamin stora de longue date
maintenant joue un rôle de conseiller
des présidents de la république là
dessus et qu'on voit bien que ça
n'aboutit pas à quelque chose non pas
par la faute de benjamin stora mais
parce que lui il joue son rôle
ali boumendjel maurice audin c'est des
choses qui viennent de benjamin stora
mais ensuite structurer une politique
vis-à-vis de l'algérie je crois pas que
ce soit benjamin stora de le faire et
réduire la politique usa et l'algérie à
la question des mémoires ça me semblait
tout à fait absurde
au fond ce qui compte en algérie c'est
la jeunesse algérienne
le fait qu'elle soit pleine de force
qu'elles aient envie de venir en france
par exemple la politique des visas qu'il
n'y ait pas de suspicion de la vie danse
la jeunesse algérienne la jeunesse
algérienne manière d'algérie je pense
qu'elle est elle se dit que c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est instrumentalisé
aujourd'hui pour ne pas traiter les
vraies réalités du côté d'ubs régime
algérien mais comme du côté de la france
lors qu'il s'agit d'assumer sa relation
entre sociétés françaises et algériennes
la jeunesse algérienne elle pense enfin
elle pense pas forcément comme moi mais
elle voit bien que les mémoires ont bon
dos pour ne pas penser les problèmes
socio économiques et la question et non
et est par ailleurs la question l'an
l'inquiétude vis-à-vis du terrorisme je
crois qu'il ya tout ça derrière et là
dessus comme on ne pense pas ses sujets
explicitement vis-à-vis de l'algérie
le rassemblement national à beaujeu les
instrumentaliser pour alimenter un vote
xénophobe
j'aimerais briller châssis à quelques
commentaires d'internautes
kriss kross sur le figaro il faut que ça
aille dans les deux sens sur cette
histoire de réciprocité hervé sur
twitter qui nous dit une guerre est une
guerre il ya des choses pas jolies des
deux côtés jean-marc sur youtube
arrêtons un peu de vivre dans le passé
il faut savoir tourner la page et enfin
bode 23 sur youtube pourquoi demander
des excuses pour le passé indélébile la
mémoire à elle seule suffit pour
transmettre l'histoire aux descendants
afin de ne pas oublier encore faut-il
que cette transmission se fasse sur
delhaize voilà avérés c'est très vrai
oui mais c'est pas le président de la
république qui décide de la façon dont
l'histoire va traiter la mort de
monsieur gouville une cc les historiens
mais c'est ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a
fait oui mais il l'a fait parce que
général aussaresses en l'an 2000 il a
dit que c'est lui qui l'avait assassiné
mais il ya d'autres historiens dont dix
kirby permis qu'on travaille sur le
sujet qu'ils disent de toute façon cette
histoire est extraordinairement complexe
donc c'est du travail d'histoire ce
travail de recherche
moi je crois qu'il faut une transmission
de la mémoire mais pas par la politique
je je je pense que si on se plonge
parler de boualem sansal qui était un
très grand écrivain algérien quand il
évoque le passage de 2,2 de l'algérie
française à l'algérie sous telle qu'elle
est devenue après il montre très bien
que le pari démocratique n'a pas eu lieu
que la transformation s'est s'était il
est extrêmement sévère
il est concret alors que c'était
intenable indépendance il est très très
sévère avec ce qui selon lui ont abîmé
cette indépendance est ensuite moi je
pense que la transmission de mémoire
elle doit se faire par aussi les témoins
du temps je pense que là la lecture si
puisqu'il faut qu'on parle de l'algérie
puisque comme vous le dites ça
transporte sa non d'un traverse notre
histoire notre peuple et il ya même des
liens entre très bizarre entrée d amour
entre ses citoyens
je pense que mais mettons la lecture du
premier roman de camus
si elles étaient installées dans toutes
les classes de première pour que l'on
voit ce que pouvait être le lien entre
un écrivain français et cette terre-là
ça serait intéressant et on pourrait la
mettre en pendant avec celle d'un
écrivain algérien sait des choses comme
ça mon avis qui serait beaucoup plus
utile que ces démonstrations un peu
théâtral qui ne peuvent avoir qu'un
effet j'aimerais juste revenir et
conclure cette émission sur ce point-là
de l'article d'arthur berda qui met en
avant les propos d'un conseiller
des manuels macron une partie des
électeurs de gauche prg et persiste à
dire qu'il n'ya aucune différence entre
marine le pen et emmanuel macron or sur
la question de de l'algérie emmanuel
macron ses bras qu'une partie du pays
avec cette démarche là notamment à
droite sur l'échiquier politique
alors est ce que vous pensez pas vous
que c'était finalement une stratégie d'
emmanuel macron pour se différencier
très fortement de marine le pen on ce
contexte de précampagne électorale
pourquoi pas en tout cas ce qui est
clair c'est que benjamin stora toujours
insisté sur le fait que dans le vote
pour le rassemblement national la
question algérienne joue un rôle très
important mais on ne peut pas traiter
ces éléments là sans parler du présent
moi c'est ça qui me semble important
hélas le faire à travers une démarche de
reconnaissance historique ça ne traite
pas le vote tel qu'il fonctionne
aujourd'hui ça ça me semble être un
point essentiel
la deuxième chose c'est que dans six si
on doit choisir à ce moment là d'être un
anti marine le pen là dessus il faut
traiter justement des sujets différents
de ceux de la mémoire
je pense que cette question notamment de
la jeunesse cette question quelque part
de l'amour de l'algérie et de la france
qu'on peut éprouver c'est à dire que
vous disiez vincent que albert camus
était un écrivain français certes mais
enfin c est un écrivain français qui a
passé toute sa jeunesse à alger est en
fait et je dirais qu'il est franco
algérien à dire que dans le premier rhum
ce magnifique roman
en fait on éprouve avec intensité tout
ce qu'est la vie d'une famille espagnole
analphabètes et l'amour du foot l'amour
du soleil l'amour de la mère est en
fonte se met à aimer cette terre
algérienne avec une très grande force
alors qu'il s'agit d'un écrivain
français engagés avec combat était donc
il prend la 2ème place était de contrer
on comprend qu'en france on peut avoir
enfin qu'en algérie on peut avoir sa
place comme français après sur le sujet
des mémoires pourquoi est-ce que c'est à
mon avis un mauvais pari parce que ce
sont des mémoires éclaté et antagoniques
la mémoire des harkis et des pieds noirs
et des harkis différentes d'ailleurs de
celle des pieds noirs n'est évidemment
pas celle de famille franco algérienne
qui ont été pour l'indépendance donc on
ne peut pas rabâcher ça va loin
cette complexité il ya la mémoire
militaire c'est à dire que il faut se
souvenir que la bataille et c'est une
victoire militaire qui à laquelle
succède une défaite politique politique
et cette victoire militaire c
des militaires qui ont décidé d'aller
faire la guerre à alès et des politiques
ils auront dit allez-y et beaucoup
d'entre eux disaient mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait là donc c'est aussi très très
complexe et c'est un peu facile de
rejeter sur la faute comme si c etait
auteurs de crimes dont ils avaient
l'intention et sans appliquer dans des
termes d'utilisation extraordinairement
complexe et violente
et ça aussi il faut pas oublier de
laisser faire n'importe quand car
rapport à la question du général de
gaulle cette grande figure française
dont emmanuel macron c'est d'ailleurs
rappelé le général de gaulle a pris des
décisions politiques en algérie qui
étaient des décisions contradictoires
avec ce qui s'est passé en termes
militaires donc la figure de de gaulle
ça c'est intéressant la mémoire du
général de gaulle en reparlera lors d'un
prochain
si vous voulez bien en tout cas le coût
de celle qu'on peut donner à vos
internautes qui nous suivent c'est vous
replonger ou découvrir le premier homme
d'albert camus et ce sera le mot de la
fin
merci encore pour votre participation on
va voir ce que vous avez répondu la
guerre d'algérie faut-t-il des excuses
réciproque vous êtes nom vous dit non à
63% oui à 37%
merci encore de nous avoir suivis en
direct sur figaro live je vous dis à
très vite sur cette même chaîne si on
peut appeler ça une chaîne en tout cas
sur ce site figaro.fr
[Musique]